on the other side davey garcia with the
yankees
he's making start number six two and two
of 488 earned run average
so two down and here is garrett cooper
with the three run home run
in the first inning last night here's
the 2-2
he struck him out swinging and that's
how the first inning goes davey looked
great
trevor rogers got out of the gate with
three very good starts a win
and a 3.00 era his first three times out
against the mets twice and
the raise once a 2 ounce in a runner a
third
and that will bring up luke voight a
strong right-handed batter with 21
homers and 49
batted in here's the pitch and a little
tapper
out in front of the plate coming in
picking it up as rogers throws to first
and he gets through
the first inning one down lewis sprints
it up batting 245
lewis was over four in last night's game
line drive oh what a play by urchella
he's so quick in third
miguel rojas the hitter mickey's bat has
quieted he likes him making it going
again these last couple of days
miggy with the base hit and harrison
will head to third he's gonna score
he is rounding third here comes the
throw it's
cut off by voight and harrison never
slowed down and miggy by the way moves
up to second for
sierra who lays down the bunt garcia
fields and throws to first
and now miggy to third with less than
two outs
and here is john bertie one one two
birdie is flared into shallow center
field going to fall in for a base hit
an rvi single for john bertie make it
two-nothing miami
here is garrett cooper garcia from the
belt
pitch on the way to garrett cooper
runner goes called strike thrown into
second not in time
stolen base number nine for birdie one
two
cut on this is a breaking ball down so
two outs
birdie still at second base here's matt
joyce who's a strikeout victim leading
off the second inning
joyce the veteran left-handed batter and
first ball hitting breaks is bat flares
went to the left for a hit birdie coming
around third
he's racing toward the plate and it's
nothing miami
matt joyce delivers a two out rbi and a
three run third inning for the marlins
here's the catcher jorge alfaro the one
two
struck him out swinging high fastball
one away strikeout number five for
garcia so two on and chew out
and here is louis brinson here's the two
two now ground ball to second
le mayhew feels and throws in time
to end the inning in the inning no runs
one hit one error two left so here's
tyler wade
fouled out to third in the third
high fly ball deep right field there it
goes
see ya it's a two-run home run and the
yankees get on the board
tyler wade made in the shade
hey it's a two run home run his third
home run of the year
and the yankees trail 3-2 and james hoyt
will take on
giancarlo stanton here the 1-0
swung on and in the air to left center
in the gap it is a base hit
going to the left center field wall
judge rounding third
he will score easily stanton to
second with a double it's a ribby double
four stanton
and the ball game is tied at three now
that'll bring up luke voight
now the game is tied at three luke boyd
swings on the next one a line drive
lunging for it is miguel rojas
caught the ball right before he hit the
ground and held on
aaron hicks has struck out and flied out
now here's the two one and hicks drills
one a deep right
that ball is high it is far it is gone
way over the auxiliary scoreboard in
right center
to the last row of the grandstand hicks
hits one to the sticks it's a two-run
home run
for aaron hicks and the yankees now take
a 5-3 lead
and their run is at second and third for
dj the 0-1
line like a bullet base hit over third
down the left-field line
one run scores frazier two runs score
sanchez and all the way to second goes
lemayo
with a two run double his third hit of
the day
so here's voight luke is over three
been stuck at 21 home runs since sunday
3-2 driven out to right field
going back britson he's on the track at
the wall see ya
that is a three-run home run boyt
hits one two detroit a three-run blast
for
cool hand luke and the yankees have
blown it
wide open they have a 10-3 lead oh boy
did they need this
and it's two and one now to sierra who
got the start in left field today he's
got over two of the sac bunt
here's the 2-1 hit on the ground at
first
boyt has to flip to garcia
just in time for the out i mean
just so a chance for matt joyce who has
two singles and an rbi in this ball game
and joyce with the base hit the other
way
bernie coming around frazier thought
about it instead will throw
in front of the other runners and it's
now 10 to four
and here is lewis brinson and the [ __ ]
cut out of missed down the slider away
so miami gets a run
on two hits and leaves two here is dj
lemayo who has three hits and four bats
and he's trying to put this
batting title to rest right now the
batting race is 356
for le mayhew and 337
for anderson
and now that lead just got bigger and
the yankee lead
looks like it's going to get bigger here
comes aaron hicks he will score
a four hit game for lapayu three rbis on
the day
and the yankees lead 11-4 padres playing
much better down the stretch than the
cubs are as judge rips one to third what
a great play by birdie
he sprawls to his right comes up with it
races to the bag and he gets the force
out of third on gary sanchez
there goes magnarise sierra over three
in a sac bunt
breaking ball strike three so
yeah hurry struck out the side he gave
up
a walk and a single then three straight
strikeouts two away
and that will bring up louis brinson now
here comes the one
two to brinson struck him out swinging
breaking ball
ball game over yankees win the
yankees win